so we've introduced you to the owners of
the attila's gym in belmar new jersey a
couple of times
on this show this morning they were
arrested why
for defying the state's mandatory
shutdown orders
those arrests come after a three-month
standoff between the co-owner of the gym
ian smith
and the governor of new jersey phil
murphy both of them have been on the
show
at one point smith removed the doors
from the gym
so the state couldn't keep them shut
before reopening last may he announced
that he was willing to deal with the
consequences of violating state law
you're openly defying him on television
what do you think is going to happen to
you when you do this
we're prepared for any and all
consequences our actions on monday are
going to be uh
grounded in the ideals of civil
disobedience
he should have just set a federal
building on fire screamed the right
slogans ian smith would be fine but he
didn't
and so he was arrested he joins us
tonight ian good to see you
tell us what happened good evening
tucker
uh so from the last time that we spoke
uh we had lost
our newest case of contempt of court and
that was on friday of last week
the governor said that uh and and
requested in court to
take extraordinary measures to stop us
from operating in business and judge
robert lugi agreed with him
um my partner and i had had the doors
removed since thursday and we had not
left the building since we had two weeks
worth of clothing and we were prepared
to stay inside at all costs
but we did agree that we would go
peacefully if law enforcement came
that time came this morning at about 5 5
10 this morning
when the county sheriff walked in the
building
and said that we were under arrest frank
and i at that point went peacefully
and when we arrived back after being
booked we had boarded up
doors i hope the sheriff was embarrassed
i assume he was there are murderers
walking free a lot of them in new jersey
tonight maybe they should do something
real
you went on this show you knew that that
was wagging a finger in the face
of the tyrants who run your state you
did it anyway why
because i'm not afraid of tyrants and no
americans should be
because we outnumber them greatly and
the only thing that they run off of
is fear which is why you see what you
see in the media
where they're pumping fear into the
coronavirus when what they should be
pumping
is solutions they don't do that they
don't ever offer any solutions
it's wear a mask shut up and wait for a
vaccine that's not public health and i
won't subscribe to it
oh that's just the most moving thing i
have heard
in a long time and i just want you to
restate for our viewers who didn't see
your last appearance on this show how
many
infections of covid19 have been
documented in your gym so far just to
give just to give our audience some
sense of the public health threat that
you pose
at this point we have record from june
june that we reopened and allowed
visitors to our facility
we have over thirteen thousand visitors
who have come to a tillage in belmar
and not a single case so far governor
murphy cannot say that about the
the long-term care facilities that are
100 in his control that have been shut
down since
march and account for over 50 of the
deaths in the state
yeah so you pose a documented this is
not speculation
the health authorities say you posed no
threat at all not
one infection and you were handcuffed
and arrested
because you defied governor murphy
you're a brave man
ian and i'm and i'm grateful that you
come on the show and i hope you will
keep us
posted excuse me as to what happens next
just one more thing to end the night uh
tucker if i could um governor murphy
asked us for 14 days to shut down
14 days today in new jersey it is day
132 of the shutdown
and i would just like everybody to think
about that long and hard before they
support his policies
yeah once they get power they never
relinquish it so as you know
great to see you tonight thank you